on the Gibson guitar factory floor
workers have sawed and sanded wood into
the iconic shape of the Les Paul guitar
but here the electronics department it's
time to get in think about an acoustic
guitar when you pluck a string it causes
the entire front of the guitar to
vibrate and we hear those vibrations but
what if you want to amplify that sound
so that it could fill an entire stadium
for example you'd use this a pickup each
pickup consists of a solid magnet with
the coil of wire wrapped around it over
a thousand times when someone plucks a
string its vibrations caused a change in
the magnetic field which produces an
electric current this current runs
through the coil and into a wire that's
plugged into the guitar when the current
is amplified and sent to a speaker we
have the sound of rock and roll
workers installed the pickups on the
guitars body so that the strings will
pass directly over them once they mount
the pickups they then install the
control knobs these allow the guitar
player to interact with the electric
current as it exits the guitar one knob
controls the signals volume and the
other the tone
now that the guitar is wired up for
electricity workers can add the strings
first they screw in the bridge this is
what holds the strings in place on the
guitars body these strings are made of
steel that's because steel can create
vibrations that will register in the
pickups magnetic field finally with the
strings in place the Les Paul electric
guitar is complete